decades into the future humanities under
siege by an alien race known as the
novas genetically modified girls known
as pandoras undergo intense training at
special military schools to become
soldiers and learn how to fight these
aliens in a battle royale to determine
the rankings of second-year pandora's
satelizer also known as the untouchable
queen is the strongest ranked pandora
during class the teacher kim talks about
her experiences as a pandora during the
last war against the nova in which one
battle against a powerful nova was
ultimately won thanks to the sacrifice
of a squad mate kazuha meanwhile
kazuha's brother kazuya is transported
to west genetics academy by shifon the
student council president and is given a
rundown about the nature of limiters
these are male partners of a pandora
whose primary role is to neutralize the
freezing field emitted by a nova so that
their pandora may attack them and they
can achieve this by synchronizing their
five senses with their female partners
gazuya arrives while the untouchable
queen is in a battle against the second
ranked pandora ganesa but gazuya
mistakes her for his late sister and
hugs her provoking an embarrassing
reaction from her and leaves her open to
attack because of kazuya's interference
the untouchable queen lost the battle
against ganesa who's now the number one
ranked second year pandora gazuya wants
to apologize to sateliser but the
president advises him against it due to
satellites fear of being touched and her
lashing out at anyone who does soon the
untouchable queen arrives and kazuya
tries to apologize despite gazuya
holding her arm satelizer does nothing
but tell him to leave her alone just
then ganesa arrives and insults her
which starts a fight between the two
despite shifon's warnings when the
untouchable queen manages to knock it
down garnessa goes into pandora mode
which is an enhanced state that allows a
pandora to move more freely in a
freezing area without a limiter then she
proceeds to beat and torture satelizer
gazuyat tries to stop the fight but
ganesa slaps him away causing the
untouchable queen to go into pandora
mode as well and defeats garnessa the
teacher and medical officer stop the
fight and they punish both girls by
putting them in the prison later gazuya
meets the headmistress sister margaret
and his dorm neighbor arthur who's the
partner of ganesa meanwhile a pandora
named miyabi takes an interest in gazuya
and wants to make him her newest limiter
after introducing himself to his class
and having lunch with class
representatives gazuyat sees the
untouchable queen and decides to
apologize to her properly he finds her
on the rooftop and through their
conversations he's glad to find that
she's a shy and nice person arthur's
shocked to find that kazuya can talk to
her normally however third year pandora
miyabi and her three limiters arrive
miyabi offers kazuya to be her limiter
but when he rejects she threatens kazuya
which prompts the untouchable queen to
raise her weapon against her after
taking a strike to her face which angers
her miyabi orders her limiters to freeze
both gazuya and satelizer and beat them
as miyabi and her limiters humiliate and
slightly harass satellites gazuya
activates his freezing powers to stop
them by the time the teacher and the
rest arrive to stop the fight the
untouchable queen has brutally beaten
miyabi and her limiters and is about to
deliver a deadly blow when gazuya pleads
with her to stop which she does as kim
and elise learn the secrets of gazuya's
abilities the student president warns
him again to stay away from the
untouchable queen because she's now the
target of the other third years who
don't take likely to those who
disrespect the academy's hierarchy after
spending a week in solitary confinement
for her actions sateliser faces another
third year who challenges her to a duel
to punish her for going against miyabi
and tells her to find a limiter upon
hearing about it kazuya asks the
untouchable queen to let him be her
partner but she again refuses afterwards
satelizer attacks the third year before
their match but she's well prepared and
gets the upper hand when her limiter
arrives she gives satellites one more
chance to find a limiter for which
gazuya volunteers despite being warned
of the consequences thanks to his
powerful freezing ability the
untouchable queen can knock down the
limiter but the third year student
refuses to give up and goes into pandora
mode ganesa reveals to gazuya a year ago
during an outdoor training session the
third year student's best friend died
when she fought her nova alone as she
believes that her friend would have
survived if the younger students hadn't
fled due to a lack of discipline hearing
this gazuya freezes the girl and tells
her that he understands her pain just
like he had when he lost his sister the
third year realizes this is not what her
friend wanted and breaks down in tears
sateliser finally accepts gazuya as her
limiter as she doesn't feel
uncomfortable when he touches her and he
can do freezing without performing a
baptism which is a ceremony in which a
pandora officially acknowledges a
limiter as her bond partner arthur's
shocked by this development and even
more so when he learns satelizer has
invited gazuya into a room that night
meanwhile a new student named rana
arrives at western genetics as gazuya
and arthur head to the girls dormitory
they're confronted by second year
pandoras who all lost a sateliser at the
battle royale and want to take you out
on gazuya torturing arthur in the
process in anger gazuya activates his
freezing powers but soon loses
consciousness as rana arrives to rescue
them and defeats the second year
pandoras informed about what just
happened sateliser visits the
hospitalized gazuya as rana chats with
arthur she tells him that gazuya is a
chosen one but arthur advises her not to
as gazuya satelizes limiter
rana enrolls into satellites class and
defeats ganesha during a practice bout
despite being warned rana makes a move
on kazuya hoping to make him her partner
much to satelize his jealousy arthur
continues to warn gazuya not to be with
satelizer after telling him how she was
expelled from east genetics for injuring
a potential limiter later rana learns
that sateliser hasn't performed a
baptism with gazuya and that she's only
using him for his freezing powers and
she challenges the untouchable queen
over who should be kazuya's partner
after a brutal fight gazuya intervenes
to clarify tarana about his relationship
with sateliser when suddenly third-year
pandoras arrive after kazuya is knocked
unconscious satelizer and rana start
fighting against the pandoras the
red-haired girl manages to use one of
her techniques to take advantage of
sateliser while rana is similarly
overwhelmed by the short-haired girl as
she tries to remain conscious while the
third years argue on what to do with her
satellites are recalls when she and her
mother were bought into the el bridget
household because her mother was her
father's mistress sateliser was treated
harshly by her younger half-brother who
abused her as she was forced to bear it
for her mother's sake until her older
half-sister learned about how to put a
stop to it on a deathbed her mother
apologizes to her for what she'd gone
through and encourages her to never lose
to anyone remembering those words
satelizer stands up and defeats the
red-haired girl with a triple axel
technique while ronna uses cleo's
tempest turn together with a fighting
style to defeat the whitehead girl
however all four girls refused to give
up but the fight stopped when the
student council president arrives
ordering the third years to stand down
as sateliser and rana take gazuya to the
hospital the president meets with
elizabeth at the swimming pool and tells
her to stop targeting satellites as it's
useless and their peaceful days are
about to soon be over the west genetics
academy decided to hold a prom where
satelizer and rana cross eyes over who
be kazuya's dancing partner he chooses
the former meanwhile elizabeth decides
to take student council president advice
and tells the third years to stop
targeting satelizer on the night of the
prom one of the girls challenges
satelizer to compete in the pandora
queen beauty contest which the latter
agrees to out of pride when she's about
to go on stage satelizer becomes nervous
but rana who's also competing encourages
her to withstand it for the sake of her
partner despite being shy on stage her
timidness appeases the crowd and she
wins the crown
gazuya is invited to east genetics
academy to meet the number one ranked
third year pandora kathy who possesses
stigmata from his late sister despite
her potential she explains she plans to
become a novelist staying around to
graduate as gazuya returns home he
learns that sateliser also possesses six
of kazuha's stigmata but showed little
compatibility with them just then east
genetics is attacked by a four type s
nova who exhibits abilities that have
never been seen before they move towards
the academy destroying everything in
their path when the pandoras arrive they
start fighting the aliens with the help
of limiters but one of the novas fires a
huge beam killing some of the pandoras
the girls who managed to stay alive were
absorbed by the aliens meanwhile
satellites overhears gazuya talking with
arthur believing that gazuya only chose
her because she reminded him of his
sister
west genetics academy is soon attacked
and surrounded by the nova with the
fourth years deployed to east genetics
and too far away to help them the
teachers lead the remaining fourth years
to the front lines while the rest of
west genetics pandoras and limiters are
ordered to guard the academy however the
nova soon release a bunch of nova forms
the pandora as they observed earlier at
east genetics who are now under their
control meanwhile satelizer is angry
that gazuya sees her only as a
replacement for his sister and is about
to engage in a fight with rana when
they're called to defend the underground
facility which holds the body of maria
the first and the mother of pandoras as
the nova forms head towards the
underground facility some of the girls
attempt to stop them two nova forms
managed to evade them only to encounter
elizabeth and helimeter whom the latter
learns the nova forms weak point is an
overstigma between their collarbones
which will destroy the infection and
release them from nova control however
one of the nova forms breaks into the
lower level where satelizer and the
others are after defeating the rest of
the girls underground the nova form goes
after satelizer who refuses gazuya's
help they both get into a fierce battle
using all their tempest turn and axle
techniques as the nova form prepares a
finishing blow to satelizer gazuya
summons up all his freezing abilities to
stop her and tell satelliser how
important she is to him which zelata
realizes how much gazuya cares about
being her partner the nova form breaks
free of gazuya's freezing and
temporarily in her normal self beg
sateliser to stop her before her nova
stigma takes control again meanwhile
elizabeth is defeated and one of the
nova's controlled girls arrives at the
facility where maria's body is being
held she's stopped by the president from
approaching maria's body meanwhile the
other nova stigma shoots an energy beam
at sateliser but garnessa sacrifices her
life to shield her traumatized from
guness's death who considers satellite
her comrade sateliser goes berserk and
turns into nova form where she brutally
beats an over-control girl cutting both
her arms and ripping off her infected
stigma free from nova control she begged
sateliser to kill her but she stopped by
gazuya who manages to hold her back and
calm her down which turns her back to
normal with ganesha revealed to have
survived and nova stigma defeated the
pandoras believe it's over but the last
remaining nova uses one of the girls
stigma as a beacon to teleport into the
underground facility forcing sateliser
and the rest of the pandoras to fight
however the nova infects satelizer into
a nova form and uses her to cast a
powerful freezing ability to stop the
pandoras as it goes after maria's body
hearing her cries for help gazuya
activates his freezing on sateliser and
thanks to kazuya's spirit sister she
breaks free of the nova's control and
stops its freezing which finally allows
the pandoras to finish off the nova
after recovering and returning to east
genetics with a change of personality
the other pandora's comment how much
satelizer has changed thanks to gazuya
that's all folks if you enjoyed this
video you can also check the second
season be sure to like subscribe and see
you next time